TREAT THEM AND NOT SEND THEM
BACK ALONE.
>> Dana: BILL MELUGIN, WHAT ARE
YOU SEEING THIS MORNING, BILL?
>> GOOD MORNING.
WE’RE SEEING WHAT WE SEE EVERY
SINGLE MORNING THAT WE’VE SEEN
FOR THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
ANOTHER GROUP OF MIGRANTS HERE,
WHAT’S LEFT OF A LARGER GROUP
WAITING TO BE APPREHENDED HERE.
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS LIKE
CLOCKWORK EVERY DAY ON THE
HEELS OF "WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PLANNING TO
OFFER THE VACCINE TO MIGRANTS
AS CASES CONTINUE TO SURGE AT
THE BORDER NOT JUST WITHIN THE
MIGRANTS BUT WITHIN BORDER
PATROL AGENTS.
TAKE A LIVE LOOK AT OUR DRONE
OVER THIS BRIDGE IN MISSION,
TEXAS.
WE’VE BEEN SHOWING IT TO YOU
GUYS ALL WEEK LONG.
TYPICALLY BARELY ANY PEOPLE
UNDER THE BRIDGE.
IN RECENT DAYS HUNDREDS ARE
PACKED UNDERNEATH THERE.
SUNDAY WELL OVER 1,000 AS THE
BORDER SURGE SHOWING NO SIGNS
OF SLOWING DOWN HERE IN THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY.
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WE SEE IN LA
JOYA, TEXAS EVERY MORNING AND
NIGHT.
LAST NIGHT ANOTHER GROUP OF
MIGRANTS WALKING UP THE ROAD
ONCE THEY CROSS THE RIO GRANDE,
THEY WALK AROUND THE INCOMPLETE
BORDER WALL.
WALK HERE TO THIS PARK IN LA
JOYA, TEXAS AND GIVE THEMSELVES
IN.
PULSE TAKEN, HEALTH CHECKS.
HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
LOOK AT THIS VIDEO WE SHOT
RIGHT HERE THIS MORNING.
PART OF THAT GROUP WE JUST
SHOWED YOU IN THE LIVE SHOT
JUST NOW.
STARTED OFF AS A MUCH BIGGER
GROUP.
BORDER PATROL TELLING US IN THE
AREA THEY APPREHENDED MORE THAN
500 PEOPLE OVERNIGHT.
A SENSE OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
STREAMING IN HERE DAY IN, DAY
OUT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE WILD
PHOTOS IN A CITY WHERE BORDER
PATROL APPREHENDED FIVE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WEARING COME MRAUJ
AND EVADING THEM.
THEY HAD BINOCULARS AND KNIVES
THEY HAD STOLEN FROM A NEARBY
RANCH HOUSE.
IT GOES TO SHOW YOU THERE IS A
CRIMINAL ELEMENT AS WELL.
NOT ALL THESE FAMILY UNITS
BEING WILLING TO TURN
THEMSELVES IN.
RAILROAD CRIMINALS MIXED IN AND
PEOPLE ACTIVELY TRYING TO GET
AWAY FROM BORDER PATROL.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACCORDING TO THE "WASHINGTON
POST" SET TO START OFFERING
COVID-19 VACCINES TO MIGRANTS
HERE AT THE BORDER.
THE QUESTION IS, THEY ARE
OFFERING THOSE VACCINES, NOT
MANDATING THEM.
IT IS UP TO THE MIGRANTS IF
THEY WANT TO TAKE THEM.
ICE OFFICIAL TOLD FOX NEWS THAT
30% OF THE MIGRANTS IN THEIR
CUSTODY WERE REFUSING THE
COVID-19 VACCINE WHEN THEY
OFFERED IT.
WE’LL HAVE TO SEE HOW THAT
PLAYS OUT.
>> Dana: WHERE WILL THEY BE IF